we are getting results for our viewers
in fact this story started back in
November when eight news now told you
about a plumbing company that just
didn't get the job done another viewer
saw that report had a similar experience
with that same company as eight news now
reporter Brian will found out after
reaching out to the Nevada state
contractors board one homeowner got
quite a surprise
amazing that was the reaction from 90
year old Roberta Carlson upon seeing the
final repairs done to her home it all
started in 2021 when Drew's plumbing and
a plus Pro-Tech LLC abandoned the
projects they were hired and paid to do
the unlicensed contractor brought in an
unlicensed contractor stating that they
had plumbing problems so the those two
contractors completely destroyed this
house she just remembers the guy coming
taking the money and putting the bathtub
out there and then leaving them this is
one of the many rooms that was
completely gutted by those contractors
with no drywall on this wall and the
carpet ripped up along with a rat
infestation that left this homeowner
without a place to live for more than a
year it had this cabinet pulled off the
wall
and had this all opened up here the
ceiling was all opened up here to get to
Plumbing Carlson along with her
caretaker Georgine barata contacted the
Nevada state contractors board which
recruited other licensed contractors to
restore this home in five months they
also got rid of 40 rats in awe that
there's so many beautiful people to do
what they've done for her
before you hire any contractor to work
on your home do your research get a few
bids on any project don't pay it all up
front there is legislation pending to
prohibit upfront payment